[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein typisches witter
gericht würde ich sagen wir machen
nämlich was klingt immer so unattraktiv
aber wir machen kohlrouladen das ist ein
gericht das kann man im ofen garen
und wenn ich jetzt zum muttertag wir
machen kohlrouladen ich glaube dann
verschwindet er gleicht aber wenn es
dann probiert dann finde das gut
so schaut immer nur wenn man es eben
sagt weißkohl rotkohl blumenkohl
rosenkohl
daher stehe man nicht so gerne dabei das
sind tolle gericht was man super
vorbereiten kann dann mache ich den
backofen meine mama macht es immer eher
auf dem herd aber im backofen habe ich
halt den vorteil dass wir unten nichts
anbrennt und ich kann es einfach im
backofen schieben drin schmoren lassen
und dann ist es liegt bereit ich da wäre
gleich dazu etwas spannt und zeige jetzt
erstmal die zutaten nicht dafür benötige
für die kohlrouladen verwende ich einen
weißkohl 500 gramm hackfleisch vom rind
2 zwiebeln 2 karotten 40 milliliter
olivenöl 1 1 200 gramm reis 50 gramm
korinthen ich verwende salz und pfeffer
einen esslöffel senf
ich hab hier etwas zimt und majoran das
erste was ich jetzt hier mache ist den
reis überbrühen mit kochendem wasser
einfach dass es ein bisschen halbjahr
schon mal ziehen kann
man kann ich den jetzt hier stehen
lassen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier den weißkohl und
entweder könnte ist es so machen dass er
jetzt die blätter vorsichtig ab zucht
und dann einzeln blanchiert oder er
macht so dass ihr den kohl andere im
gesamten ins wasser gibt schneidet hier
oben den strom so ein bisschen weg
[Musik]
ich geb dir jetzt so ins wasser denn das
problem ist wenn ich jetzt die blätter
lösen möchte
es geht aber es ist schwierig die reifen
dann natürlich auch ihr bekommt diese
einzelnen blätter nicht so gut weg also
wie gesagt wenn ihr vorsichtig zeit
klappt dann können das jetzt hier ein zu
blockieren oder machte so dass er den
ganzen chor ins heiße wasser gibt
vorsichtig was zu viel wasser jetzt ein
bisschen blau hier und da kann man hier
die blätter nämlich ablösen
und wenn man noch nie kohlrouladen
gemacht hat fragt man sich jetzt
vielleicht warum muss ich denn überhaupt
die blätter blanchieren
das problem ist wenn man die blätter
nicht kaschiert das sieht man auch hier
da sind sie nicht wirksam und können
natürlich brechen
und deswegen muss ich eben frei kochen
[Musik]
die komplette last er einfach so lange
drin
bislang sind also probiert einfach beim
ersten mal aus die sind jetzt schön
weich sondern aber natürlich nicht
verkaufen die kommen ja noch mal in
einem backofen und dann gebe ich sie
hier einfach raus man kann mich gleich
um die füllung kümmern
[Musik]
die kohlblätter lassen jetzt ein
bisschen abkühlt und später zeige ich
euch noch was er mit dem rest machen
könnt jetzt habe ich hier das gemüse das
bereits geschält die zwiebeln viertel
ich jetzt ihr könnt jetzt entweder klein
hacken aber kein kleinen rast und so
mache ich das jetzt einfach direkt hier
rüber und raste sie dann hier in die
pfanne
[Musik]
teils auch direkt gehören dazu
und detailliert es jetzt optional als
sie ihr können die zutaten jetzt auch
roh lassen und alles damerow miteinander
vermischen oder nochmal anbraten und so
mache ich das jetzt mit etwas olivenöl
damit der geschmack so ein bisschen
intensiver wird ein bisschen röstaromen
in den sap das ist immer gut
whistler anbraten und dann kann ich
eigentlich auch schon den reis
abschließen
[Musik]
sind die zwiebeln und dem märchen
angebrachten dazu gehört auch schon
richtig lecker und bisschen was ich
jetzt übrig für die soße oder sogar zu
zwei drei esslöffel und der rest kommt
jetzt hier in eine rührschüssel
gemeinsam mit dem reiz da kommt jetzt
das hackfleisch das ei und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr jetzt hier noch
korinthen dazu geben
ich mag es denn mal ganz gerne murat
wachsen nicht so sehr aber ich mache es
werden bisschen senf salz pfeffer und
zimt sind und korinthen das passt echt
richtig gut zusammen
deswegen habe ich das war mit dabei und
majoran mein treffer noch und dann
werden die zutaten einfach durchgeführt
wurde durch getötet
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich die kohlblätter und
schneit es in der mitte den harten
strunk weg einfach so ein kleines
bauwerk letters drei weg unternehmen
dort zum beispiel im eines portionierer
damit positioniere ich alles nur kein
als eineinhalb löffel je nachdem wie
großes quadrat ist so ein bisschen
zurecht formen die ränder einschlagen
und aufholen
das ist jetzt einfach mit der nach unten
offenen tel
[Musik]
jetzt lege ich die kohlrouladen und
einfach in einen großen topf am besten
nehmen die da wirklich ein top wo alle
schön flach hinlegen
wir können doch eine auflaufform
präsenten den ich werds im backofen
garen
aber wenn ihr sagt ich möchte lieber auf
dem herd gaben ich habe kein backofen
oder ich mag es lieber auf dem herz dann
geht es natürlich auch auf dem herd aber
im backofen hat man den vorteil dass ihr
unten nicht anbrennen und ich ganz
einfach einschieben und es passiert
nichts
da können sie schon schmoren das sollte
die zwei lege ich jetzt hier noch oben
drauf und dann bereite ich jetzt noch
die soße zu für die sauce verwende ich
eine dose tomaten stücke ich habe hier
seine gemüsebrühe paprikapulver und
lorbeerblätter salz pfeffer und
natürlich noch die karotten und bibel
reste für die soße gebe ich jetzt
einfach die zutaten in eine rührschüssel
alles außer die lorbeerblätter den
möchte ich nämlich nicht zu häckseln
zwiebeln und karotten dann die
gemüsebrühe nehme ich immer gerne selbst
gemachte dann die sahne dann die tomaten
lorbeerblätter wie gesagt erst danach
paprikapulver mit rein bisher zahlten
pfeffer würzen
aber da müsste abschmecken gegen der
gemüsebrühe meine gemüsebrühe ist schon
gesalzen
deswegen führe ich das erst mal alles
durch und davor bis
[Musik]
gebe ich die laubblätter mit hier drauf
und dann die so sind direkt oben drüber
und ihr seht das ist mir dann richtig
tolles gericht was macht super
vorbereiten kann
dann kommt in den backofen und da drauf
und abgefackelt
[Musik]
den übrigen kohl habe ich jetzt grob
geschnitten und da machen wir so bisher
bayrisch kraut draußen also ich hab hier
ein bisschen butter schmalz
das gebe ich jetzt in eine große pfanne
wer möchte keine zehn noch speck dazu
geben klein gewürfelt und das hier schön
mit anbraten ich dir noch ein paar
bretter zu gar nichts nütze dann direkt
das kraut mit rein aufpassen
jetzt trägt
er könnte den übrigen kohl auch innen
drin da ist ja noch nicht durchgegart
sind auch so kohl salat sprossen
verarbeitet
rösler mache ich auch schon ein cooles
rezept von mir ein kohle drittel
anbraten
[Musik]
bei der kohle ein bisschen farbe bekommt
jetzt kommt er drüber mit kurz mit
angeschwitzt sonst ist er zum binden und
jetzt direkt ablöschen mit etwas brühe
und gemüse oder fleisch dann kommt auch
weißweinessig ein etwas salz und pfeffer
und wenn ihr da jetzt speck mit dabei
habe dann ist es ja schon gut gewürzt
wir können so etwas zurücknehmen sollte
jetzt mitmachen können mehr das ist
freut ich gebe jetzt ordentlich salz und
pfeffer dazu gibt dann den deckel drauf
und lass' es bei geringer hitze etwa 30
bis 40 minuten köcheln
und dann ist es echt eine richtig tolle
beilage zu fleischgerichten oder auch zu
knödeln so kartoffel egal zwischen
richtig leckeres gericht
wenn es in der pfanne bleibt
[Musik]
jetzt ist der murat da und darf
probieren und sage ich mir gerade aus
würzburg gekommen ist kein spaß ich hab
mich so hunger
ich bin nicht begeistert jetzt vom namen
her kohlroulade jetzt mal gespannt
weißenburg hat andere frauen kochen
affäre männern eigentlich weiß aber ich
finde ich immer gegen die bundes- oder
probieren weil ich mache hier nicht
schlecht jetzt wenn ich jetzt ein aufruf
startet wer möchte verkoster bei mir
werden und könnte so noch nie da kann
man sie schon alle schlange hier 100
prozent dann werden es bestimmt eine
gemeinde und dem murata meckert hand
immer probiert das ganze mit mir auch so
guten hartmut reinicke
man kann es direkt machen das schon
gelegen
also bin ich konnte ja keiner der
romantische musik machen ja
da geht das immer so nah dass auf jeden
fall cool überrascht was richtig cool
ist wirklich wenn ich mal kräftiger
nimmt stets so wenn es um sich präventiv
chili im gesicht auch wir finden es
natürlich essen ich finde ich ganz toll
vor allem die kriegszeiten mit sechs
mehr anders essen gibt finde ich das in
ordnung ganz hallo hast du gar kein
verhältnis einschnitt wie dohmen
es ist doch so ok jahres um sechs jahren
das gibt's gar auf typische heute habe
ich da mal gemerkt das ist ein
türkisches gericht
schade aber cool ist wie gesagt viel
spaß dabei vielen dank ich gerne und wir
setzen uns jetzt auch thema der hin zum
essen mit dem team
bis zum nächsten mal und nachzulesen
gibt das rezept auf sadismus
da hast du noch mal ich hab echt nicht
schlecht
[Musik]